what else i remember being in the
bathroom another time and a friend of
mine
threatened our spanish teacher dude we
had a crazy spanish teacher man
mr vlayet and this dude he would
he had his bonus points bro people
everybody but no
nobody in our school could speak spanish
we have people that have been in spanish
for 11 years no spanish
you know i'm saying drive right through
an alto sign nothing
just no just
you know and but he'd give you 75
000 bonus points if you made a casserole
you made a damn quesadilla he'd give you
32 000 bonus points
you bring in a habanero pepper dog if
you bring in just a regular can of
pepper and wrote
uh habanero on the side to give you 16
000 bonus points
just his bonus point system was just it
made no sense
you know if you got beat up by a mexican
dude he'll give you 6 000 bonus points
so it just you know everything he did
was crazy and one time i'm in the
bathroom just doing pen
you know not uh doing drugs
and um
and my friend paul had like a c or
something or a d
and paul was in there and mr vlad was in
there
and paul was a tough guy man paul was my
friend and he still is my friend
so that's called friendship
and he was a tough guy and he told mr
vlayet he was mr vlad was peeing
and he kind of looked like a guy that
didn't have a big dick on him
if i'm honest i don't like to say that
but it seemed like it
like if you if you had to find his dick
it would take you a while if it was
outside
you know in like a you know
you know like in a field of like freshly
like even if it was out on like a field
of freshly cut grass it would take you a
couple minutes to probably locate it
but um anyway my you know mr flyet's
over there holding on to his penis and
he's uh
peeing and my friend paul said hey mr
vlayet
if you're going to give me a d i'm going
to expose your whole [ __ ] program
he said you know i know you're giving
people you know 700 000 bonus points for
a damn uh
you know for a um enchilada recipe
so i'm about to [ __ ] you know if you he
i remember he said if you don't get it
right
you're gonna suffer the consequences do
this student told the teacher that
and i'm just in there pissing or
pretending like i'm pissed and waiting
for somebody that had a cigarette
you know just just being in high school
basically and so finally he said uh
and mr vlad said okay and he gave him a
c bro so he could pass man praise god
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one